local now and good evening to you thanks
for joining us on this friday at six i'm
brian loftis and i'm christian casa this
a wrong way driver on the 215 crashed
into several cars this afternoon
victoria saha tracking the investigation
now live from the scene victoria
yeah we're by desert inn overlooking the
215. you can see traffic is moving very
smoothly after police took away that
suspect's car
metro police say they got the call
around one o'clock this afternoon about
that wrong way driver the vehicle was a
bronze four-door station wagon near the
intersection of lake north drive and
fort apache then more calls started
coming in about several crashes
involving the same car authorities were
eventually able to stop and arrest the
driver near the 215 and sahara one woman
says it was chaos
maybe like 16 cops and there was a car
kind of facing a different direction
so it looked like a car like a police
chase if anything this is crazy like
i've never seen so many like cops in one
area like around especially around here
in summerlin
police say the investigation involves
multiple victims in multiple cars in
different locations thankfully no one
was hurt we are trying to get more
information about that suspect victoria
saha live local now